in our road to a vaccine series we're
looking at whether america is
ready for the rollout of a coveted
vaccine and this morning we are showing
you the massive distribution challenges
that our country faces the earliest a
vaccine is expected to be ready
for fda authorization is the end of
november
the cdc has already given states 200
million dollars to prepare
for distribution but will we be able to
get the vaccine safely and efficiently
to the american people big question
there
our cbs news senior medical
correspondent dr tara narula
found out imagine preparing to transport
a coronavirus vaccine
without knowing where the vaccine will
be manufactured
what the packaging will be or how cold
it will need to be kept
that's the daunting task before shipping
companies like dhl
according to its ceo of global
forwarding usa david goldberg
there's still a lot of things that are
unknown and we've been talking to the
different manufacturers who are in
various phases of the clinical trials to
get ready
at this cold chain facility near
chicago's o'hare airport
vaccines are stored at various
temperatures before they're sent to
doctors offices
pharmacies and hospitals we've been
moving the flu vaccine the meningitis
vaccine
i think the challenge related to this
vaccine is it's you know a vaccine that
the world needs
as soon as possible at once which would
make it you know very difficult in terms
of logistics
the colder the vaccine the more
complicated the logistics
pfizer's vaccine candidate needs to be
kept at about minus 94 degrees
fahrenheit
while modernes needs to be stored at
minus four degrees fahrenheit
a lot of providers don't have that type
of storage
molly howell is north dakota's
immunization program manager
she says the ultra cold storage
requirement will make it challenging for
states to get the vaccine to their
residents
once a provider receives that vaccine it
really starts the clock that the vaccine
needs to be administered
within five days of when it's put in the
refrigerator
pfizer's vaccine is expected to ship in
containers with almost
a thousand shots that worries howell
the minimum increment of a thousand
doses and figuring out
how we can get that to the rural areas
is what's keeping me up at night
we're thinking about the possibility of
having to
repackage and redistribute that vaccine
into smaller quantities
and while states like north dakota gear
up for mass distribution
the pandemic continues to batter state
budgets
the trade associations that represent
health officials across the country
have asked congress for 8.4 billion
dollars
to help states distribute the vaccine
the states
and their health departments they are
both tapped out financially
and then also in terms of their human
resources they've been
running at 100 miles an hour to do the
contact tracing
to make up for a not very efficient
federal response georgetown professor dr
jesse goodman says there needs to be an
effective
national system for distributing and
monitoring the vaccine
otherwise it's going to be chaos we may
have multiple vaccines
we may require two doses so they're
going to need to be
known who got what vaccine and when they
need to come back for their
second dose so we do have a big
challenge
a challenge that goodman understands
firsthand
our vaccine team acted immediately along
with cdc
he was the fda's chief scientist in 2009
and navigated the agency's response to
the h1n1 flu pandemic
do you feel the vaccine has been driven
by science or politics
i think the vaccine development has been
driven
by science and by the public health need
but whether we will leave it in the
hands of the experts
to carefully consider the data and make
decisions
that's the next critical step the
absolute most important thing
is transparency is not over promising
and is not undermining the scientists in
particular the fda
i think if we do that and
we're transparent about the results the
results will speak for themselves
pfizer tells cbs news it's made changes
to ensure it can deliver a potential
vaccine around the world
including upgrading site infrastructure
to manage
ultra low temp products and expanding
capabilities for distribution centers
such an interesting piece i don't think
i appreciated the challenge of
distribution until i saw it the ultra
cold temperatures are a particular
interest how could that requirement
impact where a vaccine is distributed
well it's a big logistical challenge
tony you can imagine
most of the sites where people would get
their vaccines doctors offices hospitals
pharmacies
don't have that freezer capability so
states are going to have to look to
innovative ideas it's going to have to
be a lot of partnership between the
public and private sector
operation warp speed is going to be
involved so north dakota molly howell
when we spoke to her
said they're looking at things like
drive-through auditoriums and even using
ice fishing houses
the hope is that as the research and
science progresses as well
there may be modifications to the
vaccine so that in you know time they
don't require those ultra low
temperatures
and also obviously there are other
vaccine candidates that may be better
suited
for more rural areas for example johnson
and johnson if it ultimately gets
approved
does not require that ultra low temp one
interesting thing uh
west africa is probably the only place
that's well positioned for this
because of their experience with the
ebola vaccine which did require
ultra cold temperatures very interesting
you know tracking is another component
of this
three of the vaccines that could be
approved require two doses
so how will the federal government if at
all track who has gotten a vaccine
especially when people need two
installments for it to work
right and so we really do need to build
that database and you'll hear more
tomorrow but when we spoke to operation
warp speed they did mention that there
is a national database they're
populating it now
with the hope that if somebody goes into
for example a cvs in one state
and then needs to get vaccinated 28 days
later in a different state at a
different location
we would be able to track that the other
challenge is obviously going to make
sure that people get that second dose
as you know it can be difficult to get
people to come in even for
dose one yeah sure can really
interesting dr terena thank you very
much